nous parlions début de cette édition du
7 suite du mariage homosexuel autre
sujet lourd à porter pour la majorité en
ce moment c'est cette question du cumul
des mandats des élus bonsoir jean luc
trotignon vous êtes l'un des
responsables d'anticorps responsable sur
le département des yvelines anticor
association fondée en 2002 son objectif
c'est combattre la corruption
réhabiliter la politique
l'association qui était partie civile
dans le procès de jacques chirac sur l'
affaire des emplois fictifs vous étiez
venu nous en parler à l'annoncé du
jugement d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui vous lancer une pétition
pour demander aux élus députés sénateurs
socialistes de respecter les engagements
qu'ils avaient pris en matière de non
cumul des mandats vous reprochez à
certains de ne pas respecter les
engagements qu'ils avaient pris pendant
la campagne salaire ça tout à fait parce
que nous luttons aussi anticorps contre
l'abstention et le développement des
vote de rejet des votes extrémistes et
le fait de tenir en tant que candidat
des promesses et des engagements au
sujet entre autres la du cumul des
mandats
de les mettre en avant pendant la
campagne pour se faire élire puis de ne
pas les respecter derrière puis ce
qu'ils avaient jusqu'à fin septembre
plus tard pour démissionner et ne peut
que creuser le fossé qu'il y a le
divorce qui entre les citoyens et leurs
représentants politiques et donc
augmenter l'abstention et le vote
extrémiste également l'engagement qui a
été pris par les élus s'étaient d'ici la
fin du mois de septembre de quitter les
postes d'élus donc les postes de maire
par exemple s'il est élu député on va
évoquer le cas de deux élus du
département du département des yvelines
auparavant juste aujourd'hui lionel
jospin m'a fait un point d'étape sur les
travaux de sa commission de rénovation
et de déontologie de la vie publique qui
a été mise en place par françois
hollande lors de son élection il a
plaidé pour une limitation étroite du
cumul des mandats il n'y aura pas de
distinction non plus a priori dans ses
recommandations entre sénateurs et
députés ça va dans le bon sens écoutez
oui c'est ça me paraît normal
cependant nous méfions beaucoup
anticorps de
des amendements qui pourrait venir dans
les débats au parlement qui sont des
moments très corporatistes qui peuvent
surgir et donner un tel paquet de limite
que
la loi au final serait qu une demi loi
en matière de documents justement un
exemple concret par exemple cette loi
qui doit arriver au printemps 2000 2013
l'annnonce du président de la république
qui a été fait en fin de semaine
dernière pour officialiser cette date
vous en attendez quoi qu'elle soit très
strictes par exemple justement si cette
loi autorise un élu un député à être
premier adjoint d'une commune non on
attend que les promesses soient
respectés tout simplement les
engagements tout d'abord aucun mandat
même première adjointe ce n'est pas
possible pas de mandat exécutif local
c'est simple conseiller municipal
on peut le rester justement parce que
des parlementaires disent qu'il faut
qu'ils gardent un pied dans l'ancrage
local un simple conseiller municipal
qui peut assister à toutes commissions
éventuellement de municipal ça suffit
entièrement mais participer à l'exécutif
c'est à dire aux décisions au pouvoir au
travail de décisions quotidien dans les
conseils généraux
régionaux où lé conseil municipal ou les
intercommunalités
non c'est un mandat de parlementaire
pour l'effectuer correctement on a
besoin de l'effectuer à 100% de son
temps et il est en conflit cesse de
faire croire aux français qu'on peut le
faire aussi bien mi temps que si on y
consacre tout son temps comme le mandat
local on peut pas le faire aussi bien mi
temps que si on note consacre tout son
temps d'élus et donc une pétition au
niveau national combien de signatures
aujourd'hui alors pour le moment on a
lancé il ya une dizaine de jours on a de
plus de 1600 signatures ça monte tous
les jours elle est plus particulièrement
destinée justement aussi aux
parlementaires du ps qui ont signé un
engagement de respecter ce qu'on
demandait 71 % des électeurs social
socialiste des militants socialistes il
ya trois ans et qui ont signé tous un
papier
kg envoyés sur le firino s'engageant à
démissionner au plus tard de leur mandat
de parlementaire pro les sénateurs élus
en 2008 et lé député eelv en juin à fin
septembre donc c'est on trouve ça un peu
respectueux d'abord des 71 cents
militants socialistes qui l'ont demandée
et des engagements vis-à-vis des
électeurs de ne pas l'avoir fait il y en
a deux dans le département des yvelines
plus particulièrement et que vous ciblez
deux élus philippe esnol maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine qui est
également sénateur socialiste et puis
françoise descamps crosnier qui est
maire député ps vous les avez contacté
directement je sais que là ça leur a été
transmis et notre pétition
d'après ce qu'on nous a dit les gens qui
sont sur place
mais pour parler directement à un
sénateur maire d'une ville comme
conflent c'est un emploi du temps
extrêmement chargé et c'est très
difficile c'est lié mais donc non là on
n'a pas contacté directement on leur
demande devant les électeurs devant les
citoyens de respecter ses engagements et
l'argument de dire ah oui mais c'est
compliqué de préparer sa succession bien
justement c'est là où je voulais en
venir puisque philippe noël par exemple
nous l'avons contacté aujourd'hui mais
il a dit qu'il n'était pas forcément
opposé un quitter son poste à son
entourage déclare aussi qu'il faut un
sens des responsabilité collective
accrue pour que la progression du ps
lors des dernières élections ne soient
pas stoppé brutalement voilà pour la
déclaration en d'autres termes qu'on
laisse du temps pour préparer la
succession vous comprenez c'est à rien
je pense que c'est se moquer du monde
parce que ça fait trois ans que les
militants socialistes ont décidé par un
référendum interne que c'est depuis 2010
que le conseil national du ps après la
led la dictée comme comme règle qu'il le
savait tous philippe ysmal il a signé le
papier d'engagement de démissionner de
son mandat au plus tard en septembre
2012 cott a pour pouvoir être candidat
aux sénatoriales
de l'année dernière donc il le sait
parfaitement et il a fait tout le temps
qu'il fallait pour préparer sa
succession tout comme madame françoise
descamps crosnier et on verra ensuite ce
que ce qui va donner ce qui va aboutir
sur cette proposition de loi la
situation qui devrait trancher au
printemps 2013 surtout ce cas ce
qu'avait annoncé le gouvernement une
situation à part peut-être on va pas
parler des députés on va pas parler des
sénateurs on peut parler des ministres
si benoît hamon par exemple qui est
conseiller régional alors
si elle est il toujours ça je sais pas
il se présente en tout cas comme
conseiller régional et c'est comme ça
que c'est le cas sur le site du conseil
régional oui mais aussi du conseil
régional indique qu'il est également
député or il n'est plus alors je ne sais
pas qu'on a mis la règle et il reste
député mais effectivement il est il est
remplacé par jean philippe mallet qui
nous avions d'ailleurs tout à l'heure en
ligne puisqu'il aime tant qu'il est
ministre on vous aviez émis comme sous
titre député de la 11e donc c'était pas
benoît hamon le député haut donc si
jamais c'était le cas ce serait assez
grave parce que si vous n'auriez on n'a
pas démissionné du conseil régional
alors qu'il a signé la charte de
déontologie du gouvernement imposée par
françois hollande et jean marc ayrault
lui 17 mai le point 4 c into ministres
de ce gouvernement s'engage à
consacrer 100% de son temps à son mandat
de ministre et doit donc démissionner de
ses fonctions locales alors ce serait
nous allons vérifier parce que si
c'était pas le cas c'est n'avait pas
démissionné du conseil régional ce
serait encore à un autre niveau autre
chose mais assez grave et dans notre
édition de demain nous ferons le point
justement sur ce dossier nous
contacterons benoît hamon pour faire un
point et que ce soit bien clair s'il est
ou non conseiller régional et quelle est
sa position sur cette question du cumul
des mandats comme vous êtes venus sur
d'autres plateaux je vais également
profité pour vous faire réagir sur un
autre dossier qui concerne la ville de
maurepas le conseiller municipal patrick
beauchamp d'eau qui a conseillé
municipal de gauche ancien colis cité de
l'eau chaude on joue toujours un beau
show dont l'ancien colistiers de georges
mougeot l'ancien responsable local de
l'association anticorruption anticor
également il était l'un des responsables
il a fait partie d'anticorps il a été
condamné par la justice oui alors il n'a
pas fait par hasard si si si si il a été
adhérent je crois en 2007 peut-être 2008
mais depuis il ya plus de
il ya plus de cotisations de sa part et
ce soir hier pour les électeurs fait
jusqu'à aller jusqu'au bout donc ce
conseiller municipal de gauche qui a
fait partie d'anticorps qui n'en fait
plus partie c'est ce que vous nous dites
a été reconnu coupable par la cour
d'arrêt est la cour d'appel de
versailles le 6 juillet 2012 de
corruption passive condamné à une peine
d'emprisonnement de six mois de prison
avec sursis il ya eu un recours sur la
forme mais pas sur le fond ça vous
choque justement parce que vous
anticorps l'association est en train de
se battre pour avoir plus de morale dans
la vie politique quand on voit l'un de
ses membres même si c'est un ancien
membre qui est condamné par la justice
alors nous quand on a relié ça sur le
blog d'anticorps 78 anticorps la
position c'est que quand un élu des
condamnés en première instance
on réclame un statut de suspension du
mandat qui est perdu définitivement si
l'élu est condamné définitivement et que
l'élu retrouve son mandat s'il est
blanchi alors la rencontre aussi deux
choses
c'est que il y a toujours présomption
d'innocence dans notre système
judiciaire français at on pu le jugement
n'est pas définitif et il a fait et
c'était en cassation il s'est porté en
cassation d'après ce que j'ai lu donc
dans le est-ce que ça vous choque au
final parce que là on est dans les rangs
6 et ont géré ainsi c'est qu'il ya une
condamnation c'est comme pour tout pour
tout le monde que ce soit de droite ou
de gauche nous on n'est pas en et trans
partis
il y avait un côté amusant dans la
révélation de cette condamnation dans
bâle dans toutes lés toutes les
nouvelles la semaine dernière ou celle
d'avant c'était que celui qui réclamait
sa démission il ya un petit conflit
d'intérêts est tout de même parce que
c'est celui qui le remplacerait au
conseil municipal
patrick bauchau de démissionner voilà ça
voulait dire parce que crée très
clairement l'élu qu'il ya un élu du côté
de maurepas qui appellent à la démission
il est lui appelait c'est enfin on peut
se poser la question bien sûr il ya le
fond il ya le moral était d'élaborer les
teasers mais on peut tout de même là se
poser la question merci d'être venu sur
ce plateau pour éclaircir déjà cette
situation et il parlait principalement
du non cumul des mandats